في هذه النقطه كانت اليات الاحتلال تتواجد
وهذه بقايا ذخيره لقوات الاحتلال
وايضا الارض
عليها اثار جنازير قوات الاحتلال وتعمدت
قوات الاحتلال احراق بعض البنايات السكنيه
من خلال مرورها من هذا
المكان هذه بعض البنايات السكنيه التي
احرقت ايضا هنا بنيات سكنيه
اخرى واثارت الطلقات في كل وعلى كل جدار
وفي كل مكان ما زالت لكن قوات الاحتلال لم
تطيل عمليتها البريه في هذه المنطقه يبدو
انها تعرضت لضربات قاسيه من المقاومه
واضطرت على الانسحاب خلال ايام معدوده
يعني لم تبقى اليات الاحتلال هنا سوى اقل
من 48 ساعه هذه اثار الخراب والدمار التي
خلفتها قوات الاحتلال في منطقه التفاح
والدرج تمركزت الاليات في هذه النقطه
واحدثت الدمار الكبير في
مختلف الاماكن لكن بالتحديد هذه المنطقه
هي الي كانت مركز لاليات قوات الاحتلال
نحن الان في منطقه سوق اليرموك الشعبي هذه
المنطقه التي كانت مسرح عمليات لقوات
الاحتلال واحدثت الدمار والخراب الكبير في
هذه المنطقه علما انه هذه المنطقه هي يعني
سوق في الاساس بالاضافه انها مكاب ان فيات
يتبع لبلديه غزه هذه المنطقه هي منطقه
ملعب اليرموك التي يعني خرجت منها صور
قوات الاحتلال وهي تعري المواطنين وتحتجز
الاطفال هنا الاشجار مجرفه اشجار الزيتون
مجرفه بالاضافه الى التدمير الكبير الحاصل
في هذا
المكان وهذا الفعل الذي تعودنا عليه من
قوات الاحتلال اي مكان يتم دخوله يحرق
السيارات ويسحق
الاخرى و يتعمد في احداث الخراب في كل
نقطه يدخلها بشكل واضح
وملحوظ